with call of duty modern warfare
Infinity Ward is taking every aspect of
the call of duty multiplayer formula and
re-evaluating it the developer gave us a
chance to place several multiplayer game
modes at its reveal event where Infinity
Ward's showed off the changes it's
making to the way you'll compete in the
game in many ways modern warfare is
dialing back to an earlier part in the
franchise's history while rethinking a
lot of the elements along the way the
thing that will probably affect the way
most players approach modern warfare is
the map design Infinity Ward is moving
away from the three lane map style
that's prevalent in a lot of shooters
and in many recent Cod games those maps
have three general paths from one end to
the other and most of the time your
major tactical decisions hinge on which
route you take toward the enemy Modern
Warfare's Maps instead are much more
like real urban areas and mostly rely on
freestanding buildings to create
locations for player engagements it's
all about positioning buildings create
power positions where you can get better
vantage points and sight lines than your
enemies a big focus is on climbing
objects and mantling allowing you to
find different paths to high points or
out-of-the-way places being able to
climb up into windows or over ruined
walls also gives you opportunities to
flank out enemies who are taking out
your teammates from those power
positions too another big addition doors
modern warfare adds doors that you can
open and close creating and closing off
sight lines and player paths using doors
strategically is also very important to
winning fights open a door while you're
aiming down the sights of your gun and
you'll push it open just a bit and peek
in giving you a chance to toss in a
flashbang or take a few shots at
unsuspecting players you can also run or
slide through doors and kick them open
with a melee attack or breach them with
any explosive in the game for a much
louder approach you're also going to
want to use doors to get information on
enemies the sound of doors open and can
give you clues when people are sneaking
up on you Modern Warfare does away with
personal radar in most circumstances so
you're going to need that Intel part of
the point of Infinity Ward's rework of
cult Duty multiplayer is supporting a
variety of play styles the map design is
part of that support as is the new
gunsmith system it takes loadout
customization much farther allowing you
to kit out every one of your guns to
your specification even in the midst of
battle gun support a variety of tats
from barrels to sites to stocks and
triggers as in past Call of Duty games
you'll unlock gun pieces as you play
anywhere between thirty and sixty for
every gun pistols have fewer because
they're smaller
whole rifles have many more you can add
five attachments to any gun which have
benefits and drawbacks a scope will
increase an assault rifles range for
instance while making it heavier and
therefore a bit slower to pull up for
aiming down sights you can also add a
perk to a gun in lieu of one attachment
which offers things like fast or melee
attacks or better bullet penetration
also supporting new play styles are the
return of killstreaks first of all
that's a change from previous games in
the franchise that used scorestreaks
those are rewards of special weapons or
abilities that were based on how many
kills you notched but also on things
like taking objectives or other means of
accumulating points
Modern Warfare switches back to kill
streaks to make earning those bonuses a
little more predictable but it also is
making them a bit more diverse
for example modern warfare gets rid of
your traditional personal radar and
mini-map where in previous games you
could see the locations of other players
whenever they fire their weapons now
you'll need a kill streak to launch a
personal radar helicopter or a UAV drone
to get that information other kill
streaks let you call in drivable
vehicles like tanks that other players
can climb aboard yep vehicles are going
to be a big part of modern warfare
modern warfare also gives you support
opportunities with a new item in your
equipment loadout these items fall into
a category called field upgrades and run
on cooldown timers they include things
like a small recon drone that can fly
around and mark targets for you or ammo
boxes that you can drop to help resupply
your team a big tenant Infinity Ward
keeps mentioning when they talk about
modern warfare is unifying the
experience across all the game modes
right now call of duty often feels like
three games packaged together a
single-player campaign a multiplayer
game and a co-op game like zombies
modern warfare still has all three
although it switches out zombies for the
original Modern Warfare's SpecOps mode
but they should feel more similar to one
another the guns you use in
single-player will handle the same way
they do in multiplayer and your
progression with weapons and spec ops
will carry over to multiplayer we also
got to try out the new cross play
capabilities of modern warfare at the
event which were pretty seamless we
raise the question of whether Infinity
Ward expects PC players to wallop their
console counterparts and matches but
according to the developers that hasn't
been much of a problem
the real determining factor is
individual skill on a given platform
even still Infinity Ward told us their
work
features behind-the-scenes in modern
warfare to make sure everyone gets a
fair shake no matter what platform
they're playing on during our hands-on
time with Modern Warfare's multiplayer
we found all the changes that Infinity
Ward is making felt really strong though
a lot of them are channeling call of
duty of years past they feel like a big
refresher for the franchise's formula
they also help it stand out among a
growing field of first-person shooters
at least after a few hours of playtime
with its focus on new technology cross
play and revisiting and refining old
aspects of the franchise it seems like
Infinity Ward has accomplished that goal
and like modern warfare could be a big
step forward for Call of Duty
you